So you'd rather do Alaska
in the cold than Mississippi
in the summer?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
Cause I don't like to sweat
cause then you know my face
will start melting, you know I
paint on my eyebrows.
In the cold,
they stay perfect.
-Yeah
-It's really good for...
You paint on your eyebrows?
-Yes I do. No nothing here.
-This isn't real?
So you don't have hair?
None. Everything is just not-
I'm not even a person.
You're just a small
Mexican man (laughs).
What's up everybody I'm Chris
DeStefano, welcome
to Stupid Questions. With
me, Sydnee Washington.
You know her
from Comedy Central's
Up Next Showcase
at Clusterfest,
and also her podcast:
The Unofficial Expert.
Woo!
I'm scared of dying
on a plane.
-Really?
-Yes.
Because then it's not
a tragedy about me.
It's a tragedy
with me and like a hundred
and fifty other people
so it's not as special.
Nice, so you want to die
in a special way
where that could have only
happened to you?
-Yes just me. -I like it
What's a good way to go out?
Give us your perfect death.
Okay I was on a horse,
right, and
I'm riding the horse
on my estate,
and then the horse all of a
sudden goes crazy
and attacks me
and I fall off the horse
and then I die.
-Beautiful -Like a white woman,
like (sigh).
-Clutch my pearls. Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And just gets stepped on
by a horse like a white woman.
There it is.
Makes sense to me, folks.
A woman pulled out
her own buns for a burger.
-Oh, okay.
She said "these are my-" not
that kind of bun!
-I wasn't sure!
-Anyway,
She's like "I made these buns."
"and I can only eat the buns
that I make."
"So I would like a burger,"
"a medium well, with these
buns."
-What? -She pulled out her
buns
and I said "Miss you gotsta go.
We don't want your buns
-or your service." No!
-You didn't take the buns?!
Listen they could've had
anthrax in the buns.
-I don't know!
-That's a good point.
What if there's anthrax
in the buns?
The buns looked dry
I was like no thank you. I know
you didn't use
-no butter or anything, nah.
-Can't have those.
This restaurant will not stand
for any dry-ass anthrax buns.
-Not in Sydnee Washington's
restaurant. -Security!
Come get these damn buns!
-Uh, 90's. 90's party.
-Yeah.
Because a lot of people don't
update their clothes anyway
so all they had to do was go in
the closet
they didn't have
to go shop or nothing.
I feel like
it's coming back down.
Everybody's wearing
a 90s vintage thing now.
Or windbreakers
something about a windbreaker.
I love
a good windbreaker though.
I love a good sh-sh, I
like that in the pants.
I love to feel like
I'm like I'm like coming
I want people to hear me come.
Ooh, that doesn't sound
right.
I was gonna say, because, you
know
-I don't know what you meant
-That does not sound right!
But a lot of people just rewound
that so say it again
-I want people to hear me come
-Yes.
because not enough people hear
women coming anyway.
-So like, honest.
-I know I haven't.
-Ooh!
-Now my face is melting!
I'm sweating, I'm coming.
All right, Sydnee, that
was Stupid Question.
-You have a good time?
-A blast.
Seriously?
-So fun. -You know what, you get
a stupid gift now.
So because your last name
is Washington.
We framed a dollar bill
because that's George Washington
-and we gave it to you.
-Oh my god!
Yeah. That's for you babe.
This is another gift I got you
because
your first name is Sydnee
and that sounds like
a city in Australia.
-I got you a koala bear.
-Are you (bleep) kidding me?
-Yes, koala bear onesie!
-I always wanted one of these!
-I'm gonna sleep with this.
-There you go.
You gonna get it koala! Aha!
(laughs)
Oh my goodness!